DAZHI PENG: Hi, Jeffrey and a You let's talk about the data's grouping foreigners that you guys have. or this project for me alone.
Jeffrey Feng: Hi, do you. We are a bit stuck with scraping some of the websites on our list.
Jeffrey Feng: Some of them are dynamic, and I couldn't get the data we need.
Yooni Choi: Yeah, and i'm new to this task. So I was wondering if you could help us out.
DAZHI PENG: Of course I will be happy to help what it specifically do you need help with?
Jeffrey Feng: Well, many websites seem dynamic. so I was not able to figure out what to do to scrape them. I used a few python libraries, but they are not returning me. What I want
DAZHI PENG: Have you ready into the System Library?
Jeffrey Feng: I have not.
DAZHI PENG: Selenium is the software testing framework used to automate web browsers. It can similarly use their interactions with the website and then perform automated testing to check for errors.
DAZHI PENG: performance issues and functionality. Try for some of the website you were talking about.
Jeffrey Feng: Sure, how should I get started with that?
DAZHI PENG: You can start with documentation first. Re Stadiums documentation.
Jeffrey Feng: Okay.
Yooni Choi: So, Jeffrey, Have you been using the beautiful soup library?
Jeffrey Feng: Yes, that's one of the Python libraries that I've been using?
Yooni Choi: I kept having installation issues. I don't know what is the issue. My python version might be too old. Would you be able to help me with installation?
Jeffrey Feng: I'll help you with that. But before that, can you also update your python environment.
Yooni Choi: That'd be great. Thank you. Can I do anything besides that?
DAZHI PENG: Yeah, you are just waiting for the meeting for now? Meanwhile, I think you can read it into beautiful soups. Documentation
Yooni Choi: sounds good to me. I'll make sure I read that
DAZHI PENG: good. Could someone create a Github branch? I think, if I do that we can track the progress of this project.
Jeffrey Feng: Sure, I can take that
DAZHI PENG: all right. Sorry to overwhelm you with tasks. But before you guys go, would you? To make sure to report the progress tomorrow to me again?
Jeffrey Feng: Sure
Yooni Choi: sounds good to me, Jeffrey. Can you schedule a meeting with me later, so you can explain your previous code to me. I want to make sure I understand it.
Jeffrey Feng: Yeah, that sounds good. I'll take this as my task
Jeffrey Feng: lots up to you for this project, but I will manage that.
Jeffrey Feng: What would you? What will we do if we run into further issues? Is it possible to add a new member to your team to help out with the project after this.
DAZHI PENG: Yeah, I will go ahead and do this.
DAZHI PENG: Thank you for the reminder. I will send you your updating a week.
Yooni Choi: Thanks, Dr.